Hello everybody!
I'm back on YouTube!
Yay!
Alright.
For those who don't feel like, oh my god, Doki, we missed
you!
I hope you had a great rest week!
Has not been followed, does not have a Twitter account.
Because we're doing, we're resting.
What is that?
So I'm going to update the YouTube people who are not
familiar of what's going on on Twitter or, you know, on the
other streaming platform, Twitch.
Anyway, so basically, if you're, like, just primarily on
YouTube, which is understandable, because Twitter's a hot
mess, it's understandable.
What new drama is on Twitter today?
Well, it's understandable if you're not on Twitter and you
didn't realize what's going on.
And if you're not, if you don't follow me on Twitch, it's
perfectly understandable.
Basically, so I joined a Minecraft Twitch rivals, and it
ended up, I thought it was going to be eliminated at best at
the second day.
You know, I thought after two days of it, it'll be over.
But instead, I ended up making it all the way to day four
with no prize money.
Do not worry.
We're actually getting that compiled into a into a Video but
it's taking a bit because my video editors are also working
on the wrestle tuber and also on Wait, what was the other?
What was the other thing that I did?
Oh Tekken.
Yeah, I'm sorry I've had like so many
back-to-back-to-back-to-back events.
I legitimately Tekken Did you guys know Tekken was like
three a week two two weeks ago?
I think I think Tekken was like two to three weeks ago by
the way guys but it felt like it happened two months ago so
we had we have two I have two editors who do like main
videos and they're already working on WrestleTuber and the
tech in sea jam slam so that's why like the the Minecraft
video might be a while before it comes out yeah it was three
weeks ago.
WrestleTuber was two weeks ago.
And then the Minecraft arc was last week.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
And then we have another announcement this week too.
Um, so yes, before we play the game, it's time to give you
updates.
It's update time.
So people who are just here to be like, Doki, we just want
to watch you play the game.
Come back in 20 minutes because usually I'm fucking giving
updates on life so take 20 minutes before i finish giving
you a life update um but yes uh we're just trying to give
the youtube people up to speed on everything um but
basically uh basically uh i would i had four days of
minecraft and and like you know it was 150 people I got
eliminated at what number 60 something 67th I got eliminated
at 67th place spoilers don't I don't care like I literally
tweeted it out anyway that I got eliminated like you know
what it's day four out of like uh five days like come on
it's 150 people on a way to like one person wins $70,000 was
I always I say that out loud, but it's actually fucking
crazy that's $70,000 for first place And like people who get
but like people on day four get nothing day one to four
people get nothing I think it's actually crazy.
I thought I would get eliminated in two days, you know,
because I joined in thinking like Well, I'm not a minecraft
player.
I'm totally gonna get eliminated in two days.
So it's like fine like at best i'll make it to day two and
then i have the rest of the week off but then i made it to
day four and every day was fucking wild like it was like a
four four four to five hours each day and like it got so bad
that actual drama came out of the minecraft event because
people were okay so like the events were very poor like some
of the events were incredibly poorly program yes gumi hard
carried me by the way i would have got limit hard eliminated
and then gumi dragged me through the finish line for like
three days straight it was terrible um he is okay do you
know why it's because gumi got invited to shroud's birthday
party you know like shroud's 30th birthday party where
they're fucking they were doing that fallout the fallout
themed birthday party so she got invited to Shroud's
birthday party but she had to reject the invite for the
Minecraft witch rivals and you know at the end at the end of
it she was like I wish I did she was like I could have been
at Shroud's birthday party so she dragged me along to suffer
She literally could have gotten Shroud's big three.
I know, I was so surprised at Shroud's 32.
I thought he was like 40 or something.
I'm so sorry.
But like, I don't know what happened.
I feel like gaming really aged him.
I thought he was 40.
I did not realize he was 30.
He seemed, I didn't even knew that.
And I was like, his big three, oh, he's 30?
Yeah, because everyone was like, oh yeah, Shroud's so old
now, and so then I always think, like, I always think he's
like, you know, late 30s, you know, because everyone always
calls him old, or like, and he's been around for a really
long time, you know, he's been around for so long, and then
just to find out he's 30, and I'm like, oh my God, if people
think third, okay, to be fair, in games, history in okay to
be fair in in gaming I thought like people a lot of people
say like you know 30 is new old for eSports and like for
eSports which is sort of true it's sort of true because all
the fortnight pros are like fucking 13 and everything so
yeah yeah so like I guess like when you're comparing the the
young blood the 13 year olds eSport pros it makes sense you
know like 30 is usually the time when like esport players
start to retire and just become content creators because
like you also make more money as a as a content creator as
well i didn't say i didn't say i thought 30 was old i was
surprised i was so surprised because that he's 30 because a
lot of people keep saying that shroud is old and he's been
around for decades he's actually he's been around the scene
for decades i didn't realize he popped off at 16 guys i i
didn't realize he like popped off at 16 that's why he's been
around for so long and so i was so surprised i was like oh
my god he's only 30 wow not like oh my god i can't believe
he's fucking 30 retire i mean like oh my god he's 30 that's
so young
guys that's what i mean anyway um um but yeah anyway so like
i was so surprised to find out he was 30 because he was a
lot younger than i thought i literally thought he was 40.
i thought he was a really insane fps gamer at 40 i was like
oh my god that man still has his reflexes at 40 holy shit a
lot of people would want that and then i find out he's 30
and I was like oh my god he is so much younger than I
expected because I felt like be like CSGO really I mean it's
CSGO and Valorant can age anybody so like I don't blame him
um I
he's still got I don't blame him um what pro FPS dude uh I
mean being put up with like fucking like crybaby Valorant
children every day I mean I would age 20 years after that.
We're talking about Troud.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
30s is a new 20, guys.
Our life is just starting.
Being 30 is being so.
That is true.
The longer our lifespan, the 30s is practically the new 20s.
Guys, we're not dying at the age of 40 anymore.
This is not like the 1800s, guys.
We gotta remember it's not the 1800s anymore.
We can live past 40, chat.
We don't have to have kids at the age of 15 anymore, guys.
We don't have to keep popping the babies out to work in the
factories to earn money for the family.
Like, factories can't even employ children anymore.
I think, well, certain countries don't do it because of
ethical reasons.
Don't research your chocolate brands.
fiction thank you for the super chat thank you thank you in
the past life ask you if you can play spec ops a line but
it's been delisted for some time now so you can unless you
find a physical copy thank you the super chat thank you
thank you thank you uh miche thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you congratulate congrats to random youtuber
number 13 for making it to the top half thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you oh my god anyway what gonna
say oh yes anyway uh so yes i was part of this minecraft
twitch rivals even after i got knocked off apparently like
day five with the finals of the minecraft twitch rivals got
intense uh so intense that the finals was connect for so
they they try to end a 70 000 first place connect 4 so and
by the way there was apparently a bug in the semi-finals
there was yeah the connect 4 that lasted two hours too by
the way the connect 4 lasted two fucking hours because it
was so it was so badly planned it was poorly it was like in
the standoff they were in the standoff because they kept
like skipping the turn their own turn they would skip their
own turn because they know if they do a turn the other
player would win so for two hours they would both just skip
their turn and not place a block and and then so there was a
huge like two hour two hours of nothing and then both
players were like we're not gonna not gonna play the game
just split the first place prize to the both of us so in the
end like there was no first place they both like they held
they i mean i would do that too they held the entire
tournament hostage to split the prize money between the two
i mean that is so fucking smart it's like it's like a
win-win for both of them they used like i mean 35 000 it's
still a lot of money it's still like yeah like 35 000 it's
still a lot of money so so the fact that they manage to like
hold the tournament hostage and like convince them to give
them both 35k that is so fucking smart like that is actually
so smart um but yeah no and also like uh also like uh there
was a huge bug in the semi-finals where there was like it
ended up hitting like Spanish speaking minecrafters against
English speaking minecrafters because like there was a huge
argument in the semi-finals because one of the English
speaking minecraft players got eliminated to a bug so like
this the the only spanish-speaking minecraft player left in
the entire tournament got through so then like so then all
the minecraft players started fighting about it because the
english-speaking minecraft player was like no i deserve to
have a rerun because i deserve to have a rerun because i
clearly was a bug but then the admins was like it's not a
bug it was ping and so then like there was a huge argument
and they're like i demand a i demand a rematch and ignored
them and went straight into the finals and then the guy kept
it was so oh my god i wish you guys could have seen the
discord it was actually insane it was it was so bad and then
um um the biggest minecraft player that was still in the
five the in the final day not the finals but the last 20
players there was one really big minecraft player i won't
say names but you guys can you were watching the four-day
event you guys uh can like will be able to imply on who it
was but the biggest minecraft player that was still in the
like last day who were like the top 20 got eliminated or
like not eliminated but there was a chance for them to like
get eliminated and then it was so funny because dream was
watching a stream because like they were part of the
like he was like it's funny it was so funny so he was like
complaining about it and was like this was the final day by
the way he was complaining about it and he was like and a
dream was like invite me to the server and then he was like
oh my god that's just all i can think about was like like
dream is like kitten invite me to the server so i can fight
your fight like what the this is thought obviously they
didn't say that but in my because i was watching the stream
because i wanted to know what the fuck was going on i was
just like oh my god i want to know what his reaction is but
like dream was just like put me in and then the guy was like
oh my god i'm gonna try and get stream into the server i'm
gonna get dream in the server and give his opinion like i
was just like bro he's like calling his mom to fight his
fight for it dad he's coming for you kidded
like I got it was so funny I was watching the fucking I was
watching his stream and I'm like really you're gonna try and
get dream involved like what dream the man with a million
controversies like his only weapon is his fan base at that
point like I'll talk tell my father about this
I'm just like holy fuck I think that's so it was so fun I
don't know I thought that shit was hilarious I was like
really really gonna try and get dream involved
oh my god yeah these are grown men by the way these are
these are I just think Minecraft I think the Minecraft drama
is so fucking funny There's someone Oh my god There's
someone that's like an outsider Looking in It is It's pretty
funny Holy shit To your favorite 70 Bro that man's a fucking
millionaire Bro 70k to that to like some of the i don't know
if you guys know this but a lot of the bigger minecraft
streamers are millionaires 100 like there's no way they're
they have they're like five million plus subscribers
accounts like they're they're millionaires that they have
like they have merchandise and walmart guys they're
minecrafters They literally have Minecraft kids money.
So, like, so like, they don't, they don't, he doesn't need
the 70K at that point.
It's just ego.
Like, a lot of the Minecraft players is just regarding the
ego.
The famous ones, obviously, the famous Minecraft streamers.
Because there's a lot of them that are like not like 5
million plus Minecraft streamers.
But Minecraft kids money is wild.
It's true.
It is wild.
wild um yeah it's like not this it's actually insane so so
like yeah it was actually crazy just like watching the drama
and the sideline just seeing like the fights and stuff
goomy's not goomy doesn't even stream minecraft primarily
she's like she's like minecraft sideline i think that's the
perfect way they describe it like the side oh yeah and they
got all the it was so weird hate a lot of them hate the
games because there's rng involved um and like okay it's
like funny too because they're like oh my god these games
have so much rng in it so that random vtuber number 13 can
like have a chance and i was like in the call when they said
that i was just like bro what that's me i made it this far
because of rng and also gloomy dragging me through this
bitch about rng when the fucking finals is connect four let
it go and the funniest shit was that before the huge
two-hour delay the two-hour hostage situation all the
minecrafters were complimenting the last game it was fucking
hilarious they were all complimenting the last game until
there was a bug that showed up and then everybody turned
around and was like this game is shit this game is garbage
there's so many bugs but then like they played two games of
the Connect 4 and everybody loved it and then the hostage
situation game and they're like bro this fucking RNG
bullshit and I'm just like bro what the fuck make up your
mind
I'm just like, bro, oh my god, is it a good game mode or a
bad game mode?
Like, what is it, guys?
I can't tell.
You guys are having huge moon swings right now.
The switch.
No, the thing is, it's like everybody, too.
Everybody was like, was like, this is a great game.
And then suddenly this huge bug happened that eliminated a
player.
because of it and then everybody turned around.
It was crazy.
It was...
It was just me watching it, too.
Because, like, I didn't have...
It was, like, my rest day because I don't have to stream day
five.
I got eliminated in day four.
So I was just watching all the drama unfold on Discord and
just seeing, like, everybody typing.
Like, they were, like...
Everybody was like...
It was like...
They put the Discord on slow mode like throughout the
tournament.
because everybody was just it was like several people typing
like the discord server was like on slow mode it was on a it
was on a one minute timer cool down per message i was just
like holy shit people are angry people are so angry I agree.
Doug, thank you.
Superchat.
Thank you.
On one hand, I'm sad you didn't get anything from the event
on the other.
We got to see the most chaotic neutral internet discussion
I've seen.
Thank you.
Overconnect.
Boy.
Thank you for the Superchat.
Thank you.
Stranger.
RNG Connect.
Four.
My brother in Christ.
You control the Four.
Thank you.
Stranger.
Yeah, it's, it's so, it's actually insane.
Oh my god.
Oh, anyway.
I mean, I have a lot of other life updates, but I just
wanted to update you guys regarding why I've been gone where
I was the past me for those who are mostly on YouTube.
This was why I was gone the past week.
Because I, instead of rest week, we had...
had twitch week yeah oh yeah we we somehow managed to get
into twitch week instead of instead of like rest week so
yeah anyway all right for those who left for 20 minutes
because they wanted to watch me play the video game it's
time to tap back in it's time for indigo park guys so um
indigo Park is the new flavor of the month mascot horror
game what is that you may ask well every couple of months
there is always a new mascot horror game because FNAF
started um uh brought in the fan so mascot horror games the
most famous one is FNAF five nights at Freddy's then we have
Poppy's playtime then we have the monstrosity garden of
Bamban okay I'm gonna say it What was it garden of bonbon
has to be the most has to be like I don't know how the fuck
that got popular Like that I'm gonna say it that game 80% of
that game has to be like acid flips like I Like the fucking
mascot themselves like oh my god The mascot themselves is
It's so bad that it's true It's so bad that it's good
Is it supposed I'm pretty sure it's not supposed to be a
parody chat Like did you not I'm pretty sure it's not
supposed to be a parody Guys what are you talking about Oh
my god Yeah, okay, anyway.
Yeah, you guys didn't know.
Yes, the person who's right.
The Bam Bam models are famously so high poly and trying to
load the model will break your computer.
Yes, the reason why the Guardian Bam Bam is so poorly
optimized is because the models for the Bam Bam models are
like 1,000 plus polygons or some shit.
Like, I don't know, 30,000 polygons.
It's actually insane.
But anyway, like I said, it's all about the mascot horror
genre.
So now we have Garden of Bamban, Poppy's Playtime, FNAF,
Benny and the Ink Machine.
They're all in the whole, every couple of months, we always
get a new mascot horror game because that's what kids love,
baby.
Woo!
Scam those children.
complicated over convoluted lore so that horror channels
will do like oh let me do some predictions about it and oh
yeah then the amanda too hello neighbor grab those children
and get them invested on the over convoluted lore
because because that's what the children love anyway of
course i am a content creator uh the endless theories yes
the endless theories and they get a retcon and everything um
and they they come anyway so as a content creator i like
money so i also fall into the system of playing the mascot
horror drawn so here we are testing trying out the new
flavor of the month mascot horror game apparently it is
actually pretty decent apparently the meta slavery that's
understandable thank you capitalism but yes so um people are
saying it's sort of like a Simulator versus an actual horror
game so like we'll see what it is guys so so we'll see we'll
see how it feels I've never played this before um okay I'm
gonna like give you guys straight why I never touch I will
never touch poppy's playtime I'm gonna tell you guys right
now I'll never touch poppy's playtime because one of one
incident that happened in poppy's playtime
Like after that incident that happened with Poppy's
Playtime, I will never touch Poppy's Playtime.
It was, that's why I never, never played it before.
I've never played it before and I'll never play it.
No, it wasn't the NFT incident.
It was something else.
It was regarding like the develop.
I don't really like the devs of, I don't really like the
devs of Poppy's Playtime.
And there was like a huge incident that happened between the
devs.
And that's why I would never...
Like, that's why I've never even played it before then.
Before Azdoki.
I never played it before then.
But I'll let you guys know now.
Like, the reason why I'll never touch Poppy's playtime.
I don't care about the other mascot horror genres.
But, yeah, that was the reason why.
It's, like, a long time ago, too.
This happened, like, a long time ago.
And that's why I'll never touch it.
Anyway, let's play.
Indico Park I love It was so funny because I was playing
Like listening to the music of it And like it's so happy
Like what?
Oh yeah So it's called raccoon
Alright Yay Such happy music Yay If you guys didn't know The
Poppy Playtimes dev used to do like finnaf animations so
like they were uh oh crazy um before like before they were
they made poppy's playtime they would do like finnaf music
video um let's see yeah loonimo thank you super chat thank
you thank you what influenced you into playing this game it
a lot.
Doki, I like money.
I almost spilled my water.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Tension.
Yeah, I wish I could enjoy it.
Oh, apparently this isn't really a horror game Tension.
It's more so of a horse walking simulator with like, um, so
like I don't know.
That's what I've heard about it.
Um, but yeah, let's go.
New game.
Are you sure you want to start a new game?
Yes, I've never played this game before.
We played FNAF.
I actually played for first FNAF and I beat it world record.
I had a world record on FNAF, but I couldn't upload it on
the speedrun thing because it's like heavily It's so Really
programmed that you have to press new game instead of
Instead of like continue game So I couldn't get a put it on
the world record
Is this Walt Disney but like copyright free Walt Disney
is that me oh my god that's my gamer table with my one can
of world up don't miss me mom's favorite molly macaws hey
lord i'm doing some another search this week i want to come
with me what is it the last time i'm gone with you have
sucked remember the old oh they're like those like um those
people like in that mr beast video where they Explore an
abandoned island.
They're like those...
Oh, it's called Bird Up.
They're like those like content creators that explore like
abandoned places.
There's like one channel that does like exploring like
abandoned places and they were doing...
I saw one of them where they visit like abandoned hospital.
Oh my god, that's a YouTube's figure.
By the way, guys, my YouTube figures are coming out like
tomorrow for pre-order.
Is it urban explorers?
There was one I was watching that was like where they were
exploring the abandoned hospital.
It was so fucking freaky.
Okay, I think it's fucking stupid that a hospital can be
abandoned.
Because like I've seen how expensive hospitals are.
Like like hospital equipment are.
So the fact that like a hospital can be abandoned.
And I'm like that's where our taxpayer money is going.
going to like that shit is expensive there's like an
abandoned like MRI scanner like what that's like at least a
million dollars like I'm just like this is so fucking unfair
this is unfair
Oh, I hope it better be a private hospital.
This better not be a public hospital.
Because medical equipment is so expensive.
Okay, applied changes.
All right, I need to make sure.
Well, okay, the sensitivity is so fucking high.
All right.
I will be so...
so mad if it was a public hospital.
Is Soundguy here?
Soundguy, are you on?
If not, I'm gonna like, if Soundguy's not here, I'm gonna
pawn off your Soundguy job to the other mine, to the regular
mine, even though they have, like, no license to Soundguy.
Oh, Soundguy!
Alright, Soundguy.
Oh my god, there's a lion!
Can I pick it up?
Nice.
Oh, information kiosk.
sound guys here all right i know like it's not you're not
you don't have the degree to do the sound guy whoa but
that's okay we're we're a company now jokey bird whoa jokey
bird incorporated we're not actually a company by the way
i'm just me you're our first guest in 2 920 days four hours
23 minutes and 38 seconds congratulations yay hello rambly
the raccoon my job to make sure your experience here at
indigo park is the most important just hop on over to the
registration center to your left where our friendly
assistant will help you begin your adventure in the park
who's my assistant press E to interact with an object while
looking okay what do I interact with a chair hi I'm I'm
Rambly the Raccoon.
And it's my job to make sure your experience here at Indigo
Park is registered.
Let me just get a good look at you.
We had to register by PC?
You seem to have your face in our guest list.
Is this your first time here at the park?
Or did you just get plastic surgery?
No worries.
It's Rambly Tuesday.
So you qualify for a big discount on your visit.
Just follow me to the main gate.
I got a discount!
I can't wait for you to see everything Indigo Park has to
offer.
Oh my god!
Wait, how come the monitors look real?
This, okay.
Alright, this is a little bit nitpicky.
This is a little nitpicky.
This is an old-ass telephone, but this monitor is not an
old-ass monitor.
If you're gonna asset flip, at least make it the right- no,
I'm joking.
I don't know if they're actually asset flipping.
I don't know.
I don't know if this is like a... They bought some assets on
the Unity store.
I won't judge.
I was just joking.
It was not actually judging.
Ooh.
I wonder why this...
It is?
Oh.
Is this the gate?
Hold on.
My mistake.
The gate is not open.
It seems to be an error message being said the gates power
unit yeah let's see error message you get to be the first
person to try or turn on the generator oh me oh my god oh
but i'll bring down the music i'd love to show you the audio
because it's just one
what music audio
okay it's literally just one audio volume only the master
volume all right hold shift while yay I can run do I have
stamina No, I don't.
Guys, I don't have stamina.
Guys, I'm built like a fucking god.
The Imperial Violet Compact Power Generator.
But it seems to be inoperable.
Looks like it's missing a piece.
Can you find it?
It is.
This is this piece.
Oh, where's the piece?
Oh, there's a collectible.
Rambly!
Where is it?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's right here.
Okay.
Nice.
I found it.
Yay!
Am I a child?
Look at my child hands.
My children hands.
Okay.
I turn on the generator.
Rambly.
Okay.
Can I go inside now?
Inside the theme park?
Okay.
Yeah!
Alright.
Seems fun.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But, Doki, if there's infinite stamina, that means you're
going to be running a lot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, that means I won't be running a lot.
Because infinite stamina is here to freak you out when
you're getting chased.
you would manage your stamina that's why i'm i feel safer
now because in because when you don't have infinite stamina
then you know you're gonna get chased then you know you have
to manage it i know how horror games work oh every guest
needs a critter cuff that will allow you access to reserve
areas charge payments to your room and A critter cuff.
A critter cuff?
Okay.
Please have your critter cuff ready to scan.
How is he able to have power working when the generator's
not on?
Where's the crit?
Oh, there it is.
It's a gift shop.
Oh my god.
Look at all those marketable plushies.
There's the off-brand Mickey.
I assume that's the off-brand goofy.
Off-brand Donald.
And then...
Dragon.
I don't know, Pete?
Oh, there you go, buddy.
Your very own critter cuff.
A new way to interact with the park that also doubles as a
pedometer, heart monitor, and mood ring.
Data disclosure agreement included.
Oh, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
I mean, it's pretty sus that he's able to get the TV
working.
Um...
Oh, my God, my fast pass is here.
TV working when the generator wasn't on already.
Has he always been looking at me?
Oh, the door mysteriously locked.
Why not test out your band and save the day?
Alright.
You know you can buy that shirt right now.
I think this is why mascot horror games are so popular,
because the merchandising goes fucking crazy.
Boop.
But yeah, I'm gonna get my own mascot horror game.
And then you can find me on hot topic or like what's the
other version there was another the other hot topic store
the other edgier hot topic store i want to be a mascot
horror game and be on fucking hot topic for all the
pre-teens and children spencers yes guys make me so popular
that you'll find me at a spencer my new goal is to be an a
spencer store
that is my new goal you know i was like i don't really have
any goals anymore except for getting a million subscribers
my second goal i want to i want to have merchandise and
spencers
This is why we needed Funko Pop.
Because Funko Pop's are always in the Spencer's store.
That's what you need to go.
You know, if I'm in a Spencer...
Precipile, dog.
If I'm in a Spencer's, then you know I've made it, guys.
You know I'm a millionaire.
If I made it into a Spencer's.
You can call me a millionaire if you see me at a Spencer's.
In the front...
Oh my God, of course, the front of the...
Nope.
back of the Spencer store, guys.
Jonathan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't go to the back of the Spencer store.
I went to the back.
I went to the back of the Spencer.
What?
There's a loading screen?
What the fuck?
What the fuck happened?
When did this happen?
I loaded screen into a collapse?
Okay.
all right yay whoa oh the bathroom's creepy oh I don't like
it the sky fell oh my god time to use the oh my I can't use
the bathroom nine out of ten what if I need to use the
bathroom somehow the ceiling collapse yeah somehow the
ceiling collapse in the middle the middle middle of my
Spencer's rant all right women's bathroom knock knock I
think my character is a man oh hey oh my god there's my
fungal pop I'm sorry my YouTube's pop like my YouTube's
figure I don't like how it's like really quiet now pardon
our dust buddy looks like the park is going through some
wait it knows it's an I your rambly Tuesday discount will be
free percent off why not celebrate this great deal with the
ride of my railroad to test your sleuthing skills I'll let
you find this one all by yourself what the fuck is Molly oh
this is Molly I mean Molly seems like a nice nice gal oh
what the fuck I don't like that bro I don't like that.
What happened to the happy music?
What?
What's going on?
Oh, is this AI is taking over?
Oh, I don't like how the AI is taking over.
Gamera, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I look forward to the cardboard cutout of Doki Bird
displayed at the front window of my local mall, Spencer's.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I mean, they already have, oh my gosh, I don't like this.
They already have, like, random shirts.
Special data suggests you may be a bit older than the target
audience for this ride, but it's one of my favorites.
Do you know why Rambly the raccoon loves Rambly's railroad?
Did you see that?
There was a scary cut.
What do you mean Molly's gonna chase me?
Molly's a nice bird.
She looks really nice.
I don't like this.
I'm gonna walk really slow.
She would not do that to me.
Alright, but Spencer's already has, like, random anime
t-shirts.
Just bring in VTubers.
Where are my VTubers?
I like trains.
Yay!
Oh my god!
The Rambley's Railroad!
I'm Conductor Rambly.
Hello, Conductor Rambly.
Oh, goodbye, Conductor Rambly.
Oh my god, it's like the Mickey Mouse ride.
Oh, look, it's Molly McCall.
Hey, Molly.
You sure are, Molly.
Why, you only crash into six barns this week.
What's barnstorming?
Yeah, what's barnstorming?
Oh god, that's me.
Say, go.
Molly, no, there's the sun, Molly!
Your airpods run!
Oh, goodbye, Molly.
Oh, hey, there's a beach.
Oh, I don't...
Oh, oh my god, okay.
Okay, it's the dragon.
Okay, I said I didn't like the hole.
Oh, it's a sea dragon.
It's a Loch Ness.
It's friend shaped
Oceanic Odyssey will teach you all about the wonders all
they're introducing each special ride that the mascots have
I know I thought it was your he's he seems like your No
What happened to why did I get off?
No!
Oh no!
I had goosebumps.
I have goosebumps.
Oh.
I did not consent to getting off the ride.
Oh, the door opened by itself.
I love that.
Don't you love it when the game fucking...
Oh!
Ah!
I have goosebumps right now.
Oh, I don't like this.
I actually have goosebumps right now.
Oh.
Oh hey, there's Molly!
She seems nice.
She seems nice and totally not gonna get back up.
Right?
Oh, hey!
There's Lloyd!
Where would the gear be?
Oh, there it is.
In front of me.
Oh, there's two gears?
Oh, my God.
This is bad.
Oh.
I'm too... Oh, there it is.
Oh, I don't like how I can hear rambly on the background.
Makes me so uncomfortable.
Hey, Molly.
Are you gonna be getting up now and chasing me?
Molly, are you okay?
Goodbye, Molly.
Oh, goodbye.
What happens if I die?
Like, do I have to redo the entire thing?
There's no way, right?
Whenever I'm in a loading screen, I know I'm safe.
Oh, hey!
Do not shave me with that...
Oh my god, I remember, Lord!
But, you know what?
People started drawing!
Adult art of him already.
Just like Tony the Tiger.
What?
You know, the Tony the Tiger thing that happened?
Where, like, people started getting horny for Tony That,
like, the guy who played Tony the Tiger Got so uncomfortable
that he just stopped V-tubing?
Wait, I want...
Wait, is that Molly?
Wait a minute.
It looks like Molly.
Oh, I want to get my expensive rambly ears.
That shit is like $50.
I want one.
Oh, that's a swamp.
Oh, the water is not looking so good.
Oh, yeah, she wants my autograph.
That's true.
True.
She heard I'm gonna be on a Spencer's It's very Spencer's.
If anybody is like a relative Of a Spencer's executive Call
me My email is Doki can read Tell them that like they won't
regret it There must be one person Who's like a cousin Of a
cousin Um of a Spencer's executive.
There has to be one Dragoon.
The author of a lifetime.
All right.
My business email is joke.
He can't read any execs in chat.
Oh, over here.
Look, oh my gosh.
The clock is freaking out.
Okay.
If there's anything around the park you want to ask me
about, just stop by here and I'll ramble on about it.
I always need help.
Oh, a mommy plush.
She's always been my best friend.
Did you know she builds planes in her life?
My dad's name is Spencer.
Is that count?
Oh, but oh, I can just talk about.
Oh, my gosh.
The, the, um, the U2's figure.
Oh, oh, I got this.
I know the commercial by heart.
Wow.
It's the unlimited edition Bramley the raccoon raction
figure.
Push him down and he jumps.
Push him up and he doesn't.
Only 1999 at your favorite toy store.
Only 1999?
What a fucking steal.
Well, since it's an abandoned theme park, it should be even
more expensive now.
People love, collectors love that shit.
When things get abandoned.
When things get abandoned and the prices are like triple the
price.
Is this a pizzeria or a restaurant?
Well, there's no reason for me to be at the restaurant, so
let me just move forward.
I don't think there's a reason for me to be up there.
That's the Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm scared.
I don't know where to go, guys.
The only door is open is the restaurant.
But what if collectibles?
This looks like a pizzeria.
Where the fuck?
Didn't I have someone else to have a friend?
with me?
What happened to my friend?
That's supposed to go to the abandoned place with me.
Café de racion la vieur.
Guys, don't judge my French.
Oh, is there like collectible in here?
Oh my god, there's still pastries in there.
Ooh.
Mold flavor.
Can I bring that?
Nice.
Alright.
Is there anything else in there?
No, it's just garbage.
Chocolate.
How much is it?
A chocolate cookie is $4 for one tiny fucking cookie?
Bro, a subway cookie is two Canadian dollars.
Bro, what a fucking scam.
A caramel apple is 950?
That apple better come from a fucking apple tree from the
president or some shit.
Like, that's one apple.
Disneyland prices Like why Bro that apple Better be grown on
some fucking famous person's backyard We're at 950 No one
day was close Bro what the fuck is a rambly special Jesus
It's not even an enchanted apple How fucking did it there
there.
Maybe I should go to Lloyd's theater.
Lloyd seems like a cool guy.
I want to go to his theater.
Oh!
Wait, I can't?
But I have the fast pass!
Oh my god.
I think Rambly hates Lloyd.
He purposely not gave me a fast pass for Lloyd.
I can't believe it.
God damn it, Rambly.
It's not my fault that Lloyd is better.
Lloyd is like the Donald Duck of Disney.
People like Donald more than Mickey and Mickey hates that.
Snooks, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Can you get me a randomly special?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I guess it's here, right?
Yeah, the reason why people like...
Oh, hey, another collectible.
The reason why people like Donald more than Mickey is
because Disney has made Mickey so fucking bland now.
Because he's like a...
What is it?
He's like a blank canvas.
Where like, um...
He has to be like super child friendly and everything with
zero personality now.
Look at that.
You're a jet stream junction.
Yeah.
Looks like jet stream junctions being tuned up.
Adorno can actually have a personality.
Maybe a friendly Wrangler can help you get in.
Make a friendly Wrangler?
Who's the fuck is a friendly Wrangler?
Rambly!
Who's a Wrangler?
What the fuck does Wrangler even mean?
I don't know your lingo.
Isn't the latest Mickey cartoon pretty neat?
Do you know when that Mickey cartoon came out?
They don't do those any.
I don't know if they do those anymore.
That was like 10 years ago.
I want a cookie You can keep the one dollar Gary, thank you
for the super chat Thank you, thank you You know the one
word that Mickey was like What happened?
Like that episode was like I think like six plus years ago
Can I use this now?
I can!
Yay!
I can go to Lloyd now My game crashed.
Oh, fuck.
Rambly!
Why can't I visit Lloyd?
Rambly does not want me to see Lloyd.
The moment I wanted to see Lloyd.
Rambly pulled the plug.
I can't believe it, Rambly.
Let me see Lloyd.
look back yay okay I loaded into Lloyd's world whoa what the
fuck Lloyd are you okay whoa that's a real lion wait a
minute guys guys I think this might be a horror game
that's a real lion who the fuck what who the fuck let this
lion in here it's real he just brought in a real lion and
then put a shirt on it did they like put a shirt on a lion
hey buddy i've got eyes all over the park but i can't see
anything behind the stage if you're going back there be
careful your critter cub is not yet able to resuscitate you
not able to reset not yet what happens if the lion kills me
hello i should start running oh i should stop running oh it
gives me the ability to sprint but i don't feel so good i
know i can sprint but i just listen i feel like sprinting
just feels wrong it feels so wrong all right let's bring the
one volume okay we'll bring the volume slider One volume
slider.
Down to 75.
Why is it one volume?
Where are the other volumes?
Let's see.
As long as there's no blood on the floor, everything's fine.
It's just old cardboard boxes.
There's no blood on the floor, so like the amusement park is
very safe, chat.
That's when you know the park is safe.
There's no blood.
That's my point of reference.
If nobody dies, then we're okay.
Ooh, what is that ambient?
Bling.
I don't like that.
Oh, hey, dude.
Ooh, that's a big Lloyd statue.
Lloyd?
Ah!
Hello.
Hey, Lloyd.
Hey.
What the fuck?
Bro, what the fuck?
There's Lloyd.
He doesn't seem so bad, guys.
Guys, I don't know.
He seems pretty friendly.
It looks like he just wants a hug.
He's a little embarrassed, guys.
He's a little embarrassed.
Pro-dipped.
crushed by like empty cardboard boxes like those boxes seem
like empty too it's not like an actual like box filled with
stuff i got a key yay where's rambly i just walk backwards i
guess i just walk backwards right free hug got me a free hug
guys i don't know it seems extra cuddly this seems so bad.
Neppers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm just like, hey, Lord.
Oh, do you want another hug, Lord?
Wait, I have to...
Wait, this is a new area, right?
No, this is where Lord came out.
I'm pretty sure.
I want Lord to hug me.
Let's see what happens.
Like, do I get reset fully?
Or does he just stop and was like, you're supposed to run?
Or does the game just make him stop because they're
confused?
Because they're like, a regular player would just run
I want that I want to take that home and sell it on eBay
that shit might go crazy Lloyd seems like the type of
character that must have like a lot of like what's it
called?
Occult following I feel like Lloyd seems like the cult
following character where like his stuff can go for a crazy
amount of money alright beep Whoa, Lloyd!
Hey, Lloyd.
Oh, fuck you little pussy?
What the fuck?
That fucking bitch.
What a little bitch boy.
Lloyd?
Wait, where's my last...
Did my flashlight stop working?
Where was I supposed to go?
Did you try?
How do I...
Oh, there you go.
I was like, where did my light go?
Alright.
What just happened?
I don't even know.
Wait, he touched me and was like, Oh!
Look.
Look, I've been urban exploring for a very long time, guys.
Okay, it's not my fault.
Okay.
It's not my fault.
I haven't had time to go home yet, guys.
Please take a shower.
It's not my fault!
Urban exploring is a hard job.
Sometimes I don't have time to take a shower.
Ain't physical con.
Don't shame.
It's 2024.
Shake my head.
Thank you for the super chat.
you meal thank you the super chat thank you thank you why
are you so harsh to on him he's just trying to say hi thank
you super chat thank you thank you hello bitch like what the
heck was that yay mascot horror games guys in my back guys I
guess Guys, we're not bullying Lloyd anymore.
I'm sorry to Lloyd Okay, regarding update on the new PC I am
like 80% done setting it up Guys, I'm 80% done I'm 80% done
done setting up the new pc guys i promise it's it's almost
done i was moving files okay i didn't have time to finish
moving the files but also i deserve that i'm so sorry to
lord i i apologize to lord i'm so sorry lord i did not mean
to bully you sorry I'm sorry for calling you a pussy I'm
sorry because technically you are a pussycat
I'm so sorry I didn't mean it lord please let me at least
finish this game so I think my PC is like about to die um
because if you guys were not there for the the zen amalee
collab because i didn't stream it but like i did tweet it
out but like my pc was like crashing and blue screening
almost every game so then i was like oh i think i think it's
it's time to retire this i think i think my pc is finally at
its deathbed guy
so i was like slowly not slowly but i was actually because i
still have a million other projects i'm working on behind
the scenes as well so i've been like moving files and
everything oh that's horrible no molly you know what i think
what i think i need to do i do not think we need i don't
think we need epic
there you She crashed to Molly!
No!
You should have also got a new PC!
It was Lloyd's first time interacting with a girl and you
laughed at him.
Are you thinking of the super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
Say, why don't you check out Molly's landing pad?
It's not far from here and it's a great cool down after that
exhilarating ride.
Just take a down from Molly's rooftop races.
Stick down from Molly's rooftop races?
What, like, yeah?
all right so yeah like i i swear guys i will tomorrow we
wait that's money no that's my plane wait where do i go do i
go this way so i thank you the super chat thank you thank
you yesterday was my birthday thank you uh for being
inspiration as a gamer and streamer after all these years
and here feeling laughter from smile i just turned 32.
oh my god you're older than shroud thank you for the super
chat zaiky thank you oh my god you're just like shroud happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear
zai happy birthday too you oh shit now we're back to FNAFing
time.
Do I need to actually know this puzzle?
Oh no, this is FNAF.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Do I just turn it until it works?
I don't like this.
This song is too happy.
I feel uncomfortable.
Just put a random fucking...
What?
oh oh no oh now i'm definitely uncomfortable oh oh no oh i
can feel like molly is definitely gonna come here oh come on
molly that's not cool molly this is not cool molly you can't
just chase me while i'm running damn i might got roasted on
his birthday lucky hey guys the user Super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
Molly?
Molly, what's wrong with your wings?
Bro, Molly.
Molly, I'm your biggest fan.
Molly, get over here.
Don't be a little bitch like Lloyd.
I'm sorry.
If I crash again because I said that, I'm so sorry.
I feel like I'm going to crash you.
I'm sorry for calling Lloyd a bitch.
There I go.
I guess I'll go here.
I hate this.
It's so scary.
Oh, wait.
I'm back in the beginning.
What the fuck?
Am I supposed to...
Is this a maze?
Oh, I have to figure it out.
Wee.
Alright, guys.
What's the answer?
Hey, guys.
Wouldn't it be so funny if you helped me out here?
Wouldn't it be so funny?
Guys, I don't want to I don't want to go to the maze
I hate this I hate these This is so stupid I fucked up the
maze Okay, God, I hate Molly.
Molly, nobody loves you.
That's why I said it, Molly.
Nobody loves you.
That's, everybody loves Lloyd.
Because at least he has a personality.
What's your personality, Molly?
Ow.
Where did I go?
Where am I?
Oh, wait, I die?
What?
I just die?
Your stars?
Oh, there's a red star.
Is that clue?
The lethal ball pit.
Okay, we're all, we don't play these games.
We play RTS.
Thank you for the Super Chat, Ivan.
Thank you, thank you.
But they're bringing it back.
They're bringing back RTS, Ivan.
Just for you.
Okay, red star.
Alright, we got one of them.
Oh, guys, remember!
Green triangle!
Red star, green triangle!
Remember that!
Oh god, I'm not good with physics.
What the fuck?
Boom!
How?
Oh my god!
Doki is failing a child's game.
Red star.
My green triangle.
Alright, blue star.
Red star, green triangle, blue star.
Oh hey, hey, Molly!
Why are you looking at me like that?
Okay, I hope you guys remembered all of this for me.
Red star.
Green triangle.
And then...
And then what?
What's the last one?
Blue star.
Okay.
The star, yeah.
I didn't like that sound.
Did you guys hear that sound just then?
I didn't like that.
Molly?
Molly, where are you?
Molly, just grab me already.
We know you're gonna grab me, Molly!
Molly?
We're back here.
Oh,
I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
What am I supposed...
Oh, Molly.
Molly.
Did
I do it?
Oh, I did it.
Molly.
Molly coming up from that door oh hey
guys molly's not coming from that door
what the fuck that was bro molly can repeat words don't be
fooled repeat what words what the already that's my play she
did not look like I was like, that was not what Molly looked
like.
Damn.
Bro, why is Molly scarier than the fucking...
than the fucking lion?
I don't know.
I thought Molly's gonna...
I didn't realize she was behind me.
Alright.
I have to go here.
It's not fair.
My back was turned.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I'm going I'm going
That's not fair
That's not fair Oh, might as well not even run Might as well
just walk That's so bullshit, bro I hate these types of
games That's so bullshit oh my god how did she get there
okay left all right that's good to know that's good to know
it's set pathways left all right okay all right oh no I
fucked up with this one before didn't I all right she's not
gonna appear here right oh nice okay all right i gambled
correctly guys oh my god i'm so smart i've gambled correctly
guys guys i need you guys to remember the pathways for me
guys
this is bad this is so bad where am i this is so bad i don't
know where i ran off to
I jumped into here.
No.
Real.
This is where 80% of the game is.
I got beaten.
I'm so lost.
No.
Okay.
That one was so unfair.
It was.
It's so unfair.
Left.
And then what?
Left again, right?
It's left.
and then left again and there wasn't left again and there
was left again right guys okay it was left again why is she
so fast Molly leave me alone it's not my fault you're not
popular don't improve yourself oh my god it's not my fault
kids don't love you oh no okay nice hardcore I was never
gonna make it anyway!
What are they?
Okay.
All right.
It's forward, right?
The jump goes forward.
Yes.
Okay.
The jump goes forward.
All right.
Oh.
Okay.
Up I go.
And then down I'll go.
And then we go this way.
And then we go that way.
All right.
Your merchandise doesn't sell.
I'm still Molly, that's why we don't make more.
Oh God, oh God, please don't come up here.
Please don't come up here.
I'm still running!
Oh God, I don't like this because I can't see in front of
me.
I can't see in front of me.
Oh, am I safe?
Am I safe?
Wait, hold on.
I'm safe, I'm safe, I have, I'm no friends.
My run- Closes the door, right?
It closed, oh, okay, nice.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's not an animatronic?
Holy shit, he's real.
Oh my god, there's blood.
I can see in your facial tracking that you're scanty.
Transparency is an important part of our policy.
Why is it fleshy?
I thought they were supposed to be animatronics.
The park has been inactive for years.
Employees stop showing up.
Guests too.
The mascots are...
They're real?
I'm so excited.
I'm excited to see a visitor and I wanted to be sure you
were given the best experience possible.
But I was confined to the entrance for so long.
I didn't realize just how much disrepair the park is.
Remley, there's a dead fucking bird on my floor.
Yeah, I'm having so much fun.
But I have an idea.
I have access to the repair documentation in my database.
I just can't execute most tasks without authorization from a
human user.
You must have come here because the park matters to you too,
right?
Sure.
Would you be willing to help me?
You're seeing your facial tracking data that you aren't
opposed to this.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Let's get this place back in business.
Oh, I don't know.
Working with an AI, Terminator taught me that I shouldn't be
doing that.
Rookie Wrangler.
Registered.
Your first official job as one of Rambly's Ranglers.
Is to get out of the Rambly's Rangler's Registered Room.
left towards the rookie wrangler register security room to
set yourself free oh okay kind of exhausting to say that
whole should i just a wrangler's register is a register
trademark that expired yesterday whoa guys you hear that the
trademark expired uh that means we can take it and make it's
like the the mickey mouse really boat seam boat we can make
our own content
Can we go here?
Wranglers only?
I'm a wrangler.
It's public domain!
Well, technically not public domain, but it doesn't have a
trademark.
Is there any freaky dolls outside?
No.
All the security seems fine.
Let's make a rambly horror film!
Because that's what people do when a fucking trademark goes
expired, or things go public domain people just make horror
films because it's the cheapest all right let's head up
yay we made it we survived we survived guys so easy oh who's
this who's pluto oh it's the pluto wait she doesn't seem to
be an indigo plus found no surprise i guess that our park
would dispose of a non-indigo brand toy i suppose he'd make
playtime special for a child with poor taste though damn
rambly that's up at least that poodle might still have a
franchise all right thank you the super chatting thank you
fun fact ball pits and playground city castles used to exist
wonder why they all disappeared germs covid
Oceanic Odyssey?
I did it.
Go in.
There's nobody here.
Can I go in?
There's a lot of loading screens.
Not gonna let.
Is that it?
You look kind of tired.
Do you need a moment?
Don't worry.
I don't blame you for taking a rest after all that.
Heck, I could go for a nice, relaxing defragmentation
myself.
But before you settle down, you up for a little survey to
help us improve the park?
Thanks for visiting into the park.
Oh, it has its own song!
If you've got some time and you're up for a lark, stick
around for the rambly review.
I'm here to offer my best to each valuable guest I assist.
I get to exist Were you satisfied with the rights?
No Were you satisfied with your guide?
Do you plan to come back?
No!
Did your experience get you to tell a friend about us?
Did I earn your trust?
No!
At Indigo Park There is a stark contrast to everything I
know this place should be But out of the dark You You've
given a spark of sunshine to this kingdom's faithful
devotee.
At Indigo Park, more than my remarks are, mysteries even I
don't know what we might find.
Fight for your deck.
And I'll be your spark of sunshine to get you out of any
bind.
That is, if you want to keep going.
idea.
I know all of this isn't fair to you.
It's an awful lot to add.
This song is nice though.
It's a really nice song in general.
Yeah, that was it.
I heard it was like a really short because it's chapter one.
I mean it's free.
By the way, this game is free.
Which is better than like, you know, other mascot horror
games that make you buy each chapter including chapter one.
So like, you know, I'm glad it's free.
Yeah, at least for free games you have to buy chapter one a
garden and bonbon chat
I'm pretty sure like chapter one's free and then it hooks
you in for like the for people who like mascot horror genres
And like And then they make you buy chapter two Yoki cover
when koala they give you the same Super chat, thank you,
thank you.
It's actually surprising.
When I uploaded the, when I uploaded the shark, the short,
sorry shark, the short for a friend like me, people didn't
realize I sang that in karaoke.
So people were like, people were like, oh my God, upload the
full song.
Where did you sing this?
I'm like, two months ago?
I was just like, one one two months ago so that's just like
what do you mean like upload the full cover i'm saying that
like a long time ago it's still there it's still there i
mean that's enjoyable i mean it is it's a full passionate
project i mean like i'm gonna say it it follows the formula
so if you like mascot horror game you'll like indigo park
like it's it's very it's it works the formula works people
make like five million theories already i swear if i like
youtube like um if i youtube like indigo park theories
there's gonna be like five million theories already but like
i feel like it works so uh so like that's why like these
these types of genres like really popular and like clearly
indigo park is like it's a john it's a genre that works
really well like uh it follows the mascot horror genre and
it works very well in that aspect oh it's the devs in my
chat main writer voice actor of lord and isaac and composer
of half the songs including the rambly review hope you enjoy
the first chapter and thanks for playing thank you thank you
for coming over to watch my playthrough oh my god bro bro
lord fucking i'm sorry for calling And then he like made my
PC blue screen after I said that.
I'm sorry
Now I'm a Lord fan now
Things are coming over.
I don't know you saw that part.
I didn't mean it Lord's my oh she now and Lord's my favorite
character in Indigo Park Indirected he put me in up in his
he put me in his place
um but like yeah it's a free game and um it clearly sets up
a lot of like like the story building and everything and
like they're real from what i i think they're real when that
bird when molly's head came off and there's blood everywhere
that seems so real i think they're real creatures guys
But yeah, you can check it out.
It's for free.
It is, like, episodic.
So, like, I don't think I'll be...
I don't know if I want to play...
I don't know.
Maybe I'll play Chapter 2 when it comes out, just for, like,
FOMO.
You know, like, everybody will be playing Chapter 2.
So then I might as well experience Chapter 2 with all of you
guys when it comes out.
So, yeah.
It's a free game.
So, like, it doesn't hurt.
and i assume that chapter two chapter two and the rest will
be uh will be paid uh just because like that's usually how
it goes when it comes to mascot horror games um but yeah uh
let me go back to my chatting screen i enjoyed it so far uh
the lore building because it's it's the usual type of um
it's there to like hook you in and to be like oh what's
going gonna happen next in indigo park how get abandoned.
Why is that a real lion?
Why is there a real lion in there and not a fake lion?
Where did the real lion come from?
There was an arcade.
Oh my god, I missed a lot of stuff.
I didn't even realize there was an arcade in there.
Apparently I missed a scene where happen and I wasn't
looking at it that happens a lot final next okay indigo park
uh what's his name the eeyore dragon what was the eeyore
dragon's name um uh eeyore what was his name again I just
remember him as eeyore dragon I know Molly's name oh Finley
okay Finley ending Alright, guys.
I'm going to watch it.
I'm going to steal somebody's content.
I'm going to steal the content.
Alright, where is he?
It's like here, right?
Alright.
Here you go.
I'm looking at the ending.
Alright.
Oh, there he is.
Why didn't I see?
that bro he just okay that's the jump scare he just flies
over he just he just fucking swims over god i didn't realize
that was the jump scare all right all right so that was the
jump scene i thought there was like other i thought to know.
That's nice to know.
Oh, there's the arcade.
Oh, if you beat the arcade game, things go freaking crazy.
The arcade machine, Rambly Rush, is where most of the rest
of my music was.
There's also a fully animated official music video of the
Kratos theme on my channel.
Oh, shit.
There's a fully... Oh, nice.
The music was really good.
I really enjoyed the music.
Oh, I see it.
Here's the music.
if anyone wants to check out the full music but yeah thanks
for dropping by thanks for dropping by i'm glad to be able
to play your game sir oh best all right super chat reading
time guys okay all right all right i promise you guys this
today i will set up my pc like i'm not gaslighting this time
because i'm 70 done If tomorrow, if tomorrow, I, the PC is
not set up by tomorrow's Sandland stream, you get to request
anything as a group from me.
One thing, you get to request anything as a group, though.
You guys have to agree as a group, though.
You have to agree together as a hive mind what you want.
I didn't think it was super chat.
Thank you.
um um but i will i will set up the pc by tomorrow before the
sand land stream so we'll finally be free
it'll finally visage was already gonna be played anyway chat
it was already gonna be played we reached the goal did we
yeah we did we reached the charity goal so like Look, see,
I'm so generous.
I could have lied.
I could have lied and was like, oh, I don't know about
Vassage.
All right.
Well, you guys, what?
Guys, I like how you're all like coming up with ideas now,
not believing that I'm going to set up my PC.
I am going to set up my PC by tomorrow.
So you guys, so don't even need to think about it.
You guys don't even need to think about like the punishment.
because it's gonna be done chat that's the thing if you're
thinking about it now it's a waste of your time
cas another dokey karaoke thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you thank you duck thank you the super chat thank
you we heard that one but this time look because blue screen
is a little bit too much if like the game crashes like once
every once in a while but the blue screen is sort of the the
blue screen is where I have to draw the line that's when I
know that my PC is literally begging it is like it's like
crawling itself to the grave right now my PC is literally
just try like crawling to its coffin and like please bury me
please I beg of you I am blue screening bury me leave me to
die Like, that's when I know That I have to I have to let it
rest in peace for real Zero, thank you for the super chat
Thank you, thank you Eldering and Visage Cosmic, thank you
for the super chat Thank you, thank you It's been weeks,
Doki Look, that's what I'm saying I am finally going to make
sure My PC is finally left to rest Because it's literally at
its dying knees right now wanting me to put like you know
like that what there's a hole in front the pc dug its own
hole gave me a pistol and was like please just end the blue
screen was a sign it's never blue screen before when all the
problems were have when when we're having all these problems
but now that it's starting to blue screen.
It is time to lay it to rest.
Zai, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kubey, thank you.
All right, best.
Spend the boss a reel if it isn't ready tomorrow.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Guys, stop coming up with ideas.
We're going to have it set up.
Okay, what do I get when I set it up?
Chat.
What do you?
A working PC.
Okay, that is true.
I get a working PC, but also what else do I get?
But there should be more.
Okay, guys, I'm gonna call it here.
I had a great time hanging out with you guys back on...
We're back on YouTubes!
Yeah!
Anyway, guys, I'll see you guys tomorrow.
It was a short stream today But it's more like an appetizer
today Because we do have a sort of long week filled with
lots of streams This week So uh Scourge, you get a super
chat Thank you, thank you If it don't, you don't said
tomorrow You have to eat more hot sauce Think of a super
chat, thank you, thank you Jokes on you, I like hot sauce
I'm Asian We can handle the sauce Hey guys, it might be a
short stream today But like I said, it's sort of like a
little appetizer For the long week of solo streams uh had a
great time just talking with you guys again like as a solo
like just like you know to the dragoons mostly uh so like
collab it's great time to just have like you know dragoon
time with you guys um yes i'm gonna uh finish saving some
migrating my files and everything to the new pc so i'll i
fucking felt like i had a stroke there like i couldn't
verbalize i'm not gonna do that my words were just tangled
up um i'm gonna go head off now as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you stayed up for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye